roadtrippers today
[Music]
so that good position on him it'll be a
deep triple Kevin Love did not too well
from beyond the arc compels too
this is an excellent pass by Londo
so explosive in the foot water
looks like he's just kind of walking all
of a sudden you get to the baseline and
let's like but their schedules that is
difficult to some of the teams ahead of
them my speed inside boy loves all Pauls
it's right apart
he's always looking to do that
[Music]
the basketball
[Applause]
they're eight for 16
big man
six early - we all storm road trip today
this is what's on the spins goes to the
rim and waits for the past nearly came
in and took the rebound away from for
one jerseys ball ridiculous is so
athletically gifted I mean look you bet
guys are even anticipating and he's just
filling
in that position when that young team
gets the ball moving they can be scary
that's why another reason out butt was
so frustrated here we go
throwing up when sion do his thing
there is no timeout on the floor
[Applause]
Oh boasts a full court man pass right
here this is not an easy pass to me
get the dough to go
[Applause]
[Music]
you side out of bounds New Orleans
[Applause]
there is Z see he was at the top of the
circle
this defensive band got caught no idea
where the ball was went up at - boy Adam
left coach you like that content I know
you like that content it subscribe for
more of it boo bleacher